las necesidades de asistencia
humanitaria se han multiplicado
la desigualdad por desgracia ha crecido
y los efectos del cambio climático se
han agravado también
a la seguridad sanitaria debilitada por
la pandemia se agrega una grave amenaza
para la seguridad alimentaria en amplias
capas de la población de los países más
pobres y marginados el contexto el
contexto actual se caracteriza además
por el aumento de las tensiones
geopolíticas entre las principales
potencias
cuando parecía que vendría la
recuperación de los graves efectos que
tuvo la pandemia por el 19
emerge la guerra en Ucrania
con el riesgo de un accidente nuclear y
sus potenciales consecuencias
catastróficas
además de Los Altos costos en vidas
humanas y las afectaciones a millones de
personas desplazadas
internas y refugiadas en otros países la
guerra en Ucrania ha impactado la
disponibilidad de alimentos y de
combustibles en todo el mundo
esta guerra se suma a otros conflictos
armados que permanecen sin solución y
por lo mismo la cera gravemente la
armonía y el orden internacional
fundados en el derecho internacional
México como estado responsable y
comprometido con la promoción de la
solución pacífica de las controversias
acude a esta asamblea general con una
propuesta para el diálogo y la paz en
Ucrania que expondré a continuación
brevemente
el Consejo de Seguridad hay que decirlo
no ha podido cumplir con el mandato que
le confiere la carta de las Naciones
Unidas
al no haber conseguido prevenir la
guerra ni tampoco tomado las medidas que
pongan un alto a la agresión Armada
menos aún Ha logrado encaminar proceso
diplomático alguno para buscar una
solución por la vía del diálogo y la
negociación
debemos decir que tampoco ha podido
lograr que llegue todo el suministro de
asistencia humanitaria requerido
y tampoco por desgracia respaldar
abiertamente la labor del secretario
general y de otros actores por gestionar
el acceso a los mercados de granos y
fertilizantes producidos por la
federación de Rusia y por Ucrania
ante esta parálisis
hemos tenido que recurrir a la asamblea
general en una sesión especial de
emergencia en la que México junto con
Francia planteó el marco adecuado para
canalizar la ayuda humanitaria a través
de la resolución e-11 diagonal 2 que sin
duda ha sido útil pero que resulta
claramente insuficiente ante la Estela
de destrucción y sufrimiento que ha
dejado la guerra
por tales razones el presidente de
México
el licenciado López Obrador consciente
de la responsabilidad individual y
colectiva que tenemos
propone que una comitiva al coco cruz de
jefes de estado y de gobierno aliente y
acompañe los esfuerzos de secretario
general para promover medidas de fomento
de la confianza hoy perdida entre la
federación rusa y Ucrania que permitan
generar las condiciones tan pronto sea
posible para acercar a las partes a los
mecanismos de solución pacífica de las
controversias que señala la carta de las
Naciones Unidas
Dicho de otro modo
ante la parálisis del Consejo de
Seguridad
debemos ofrecer entre todos un canal
diplomático complementario los
existentes para interactuar con las
partes en conflicto con miras a reducir
las tensiones y en causar la mediación
indispensable
esa propuesta ha sido compartida En días
pasados con el secretario general y con
las partes involucradas así como con las
delegaciones de la India y de la santa
sede toda vez que el presidente López
Obrador considera que en dicha comitiva
debieran participar junto con el
secretario general de la ONU entre otros
su excelencia en adentra modi y su
santidad del Papa Francisco
vamos a proseguir con las consultas
necesarias con el único propósito de
poder contribuir como actor Imparcial y
de buena fe a general más amplio
respaldo posible a las gestiones y
buenos oficios de Antonio Gutiérrez y
del cáucus cuya conformación Esperamos
que proceda con el apoyo de los estados
miembros de la ONU
en estos casi dos años como Miembro
electo el Consejo de Seguridad México ha
procurado adentrarse en las causas
estructurales de los conflictos y
promover la diplomacia preventiva como
elementos central para el mantenimiento
de la paz y la seguridad internacional
hemos traído a la mesa del Consejo temas
que se habían dejado de lado tales como
la pobreza la corrupción y desigualdad
como factores subyacentes del conflicto
de salud
la Salud Mental como objetivo ineludible
de la ayuda humanitaria las nociones de
masculinidades para prevenir la
radicalización del terrorismo
la importancia de respetar el sistema de
seguridad colectiva establecido en la
carta y la necesidad de una coordinación
y cooperación para la paz entre los
órganos principales de la ONU
los flujos ilícitos de armas pequeñas y
ligeras como resultado de Francia
disponibilidad
vulneran la seguridad regional e
internacional es por ello que México ha
insistido en la necesidad de tomar
medidas para detener estos flujos de
armas
prueba de ello también fue lograr que el
Consejo de Seguridad adoptar a la
resolución 26:16 en 2021 que está
encaminada a respetar los embargos de
armas ya que las operaciones de paz
coadyuven a reforzar las capacidades de
las autoridades nacionales en el combate
al tráfico y al desvío ilícitos de armas
hemos pugnado también en favor de la
transparencia la eficacia y la rendición
de cuentas y la participación equitativa
en los trabajos del Consejo en ese
sentido México Va a continuar abogando
por una reforma integral del Consejo de
Seguridad que incluya más asientos con
términos más largos de mandatos en la
categoría de miembros electos para
hacerlo más representativo transparente
y eficiente la parálisis del Consejo de
Seguridad resultados del abuso del mal
llamado derecho de Beto por parte de
algunos de sus miembros permanentes
incluso durante esta asamblea dos de
ellos se refirieron explícitamente a la
necesidad de restringir su uso a
situaciones realmente excepcionales en
ese tenor México y Francia hemos seguido
promoviendo que los miembros permanentes
se abstengan de recurrir al veto ante
situaciones de atrocidades masivas
invitamos a los estados que aún no lo
han hecho asomarse esta iniciativa que
cuenta ya con el respaldo de 106 estados
entre tanto México y otros 83 estados
impulsamos un mecanismo de rendición de
cuentas por el que cada vez que se
registra un reto en el Consejo de
Seguridad la asamblea general se reúna
sin dilación para debatir la cuestión E
invita al autor o autores del veto
explicar su posición
esta propuesta que fue adoptada por
unanimidad mediante la resolución 76
diagonal 262 y ya se ha activado en dos
ocasiones apunta en la dirección
correcta
toca ahora decidir si queremos dar los
pasos subsecuentes para evitar que el
sistema se siga paralizando frente al
sufrimiento masivo de personas
las armas nucleares
siguen representando la peor amenaza
para la supervivencia misma de la
humanidad
México lamenta la falta de voluntad
política
particularmente por parte de los estados
poseedores de armas nucleares para
alcanzar acuerdos que permitan lograr
dicho propósito algo que Quedó
confirmado En la reciente conferencia de
examen del tratado de no proliferación
que no alcanzó resultado alguno aún y
cuando los riesgos de proliferación
nuclear son cada día más reales y
evidentes
mi país
coincide con la visión del secretario
general de que un mundo más seguro y en
paz debe estar asentado en el derecho
internacional la cooperación y la
solidaridad y no en la incesante
acumulación y modernización de los
arsenales nucleares y convencionales
justamente fue esta visión la que llevó
a los países de América Latina y el
Caribe a establecer la primera zona
libre de armas nucleares en un área
densamente poblada a través del tratado
Tlatelolco y la que condujo a la
conclusión y entrada en vigor en años
recientes del tratado sobre la
prohibición de las armas nucleares señor
presidente colegas
México reafirma que las Naciones Unidas
continúan siendo una herramienta única
de la comunidad internacional para la
resolución pacífica de controversias y
la consecución de los objetivos de la
agenda 2030 para el desarrollo
sostenible
nuestro país seguirá promoviendo el
multilateralismo la solidaridad
internacional y la cooperación como la
mejor vía para enfrentar los desafíos
globales
no podemos cerrar la puerta al diálogo
político y la negociación diplomática
las actuales tensiones internacionales
no van a solucionarse por la vida de la
fuerza
debemos asegurar entendimientos
políticos y mecanismos de construcción
de la confianza sí restaurar la
confianza es uno de nuestros mayores
retos hoy
México es un llamado a todos los estados
miembros a trabajar conjuntamente para
alcanzar la paz que todos anhelamos a
trabajar Unidos en la recuperación post
pandemia con un empaque sostenible y
resiliente que contemple cabalmente las
necesidades y las prioridades de todos
los países y que pongan las personas en
el centro de nuestras acciones Muchas
gracias